now that you know what the conic
sections are and why they're called
conic sections let's see if we can
understand the actual equations of the
conic sections a little bit better and
and use that knowledge to be able to at
least recognize them when we see the
equation and then if we see the equation
know how to plot them
so the first one we'll start off with is
the circle
and you've probably seen this for many
years already but i'll review if you
don't know it already the general form
of of of an equation or the general
equation for a circle is
x squared
plus y squared is equal to
r squared where r is the radius of the
circle and this would be a circle
centered at the point 0 0 so i'll just
draw this kind of general graph right
here
so if that's the x-axis
that's the y-axis
the circle will look like this let me do
it in a different color
the circle would look something like
make sure it's a circle
well it's supposed to be centered at 0 0
but that's close enough
so its center will be right here and the
radius if you go from the center to any
point along that circle will be have a
distance of r so you go from there to
there it's r from there there it's r
from there to there it's r
and to some degree this this formula all
it is is an extension of the distance
formula which is really just the
extension of the pythagorean theorem so
for example the distance formula if i
want to know the distance between some
point
x comma y
and the point
zero zero what you do is you take the
difference of the x's so x minus zero
you square that and then you add that to
the
distance between the y's squared so
that's one y point minus
zero y y is equal to zero square that
and that is equal to the distance
squared
so if you simplify simplify this x minus
zero square root that's just x squared
plus and this is just
y squared
is equal to distance squared so
essentially this equation is the plot of
all points that are exactly d away a
distance of d away from the point 0 0
and that's just a circle and i'll let
you think about i think i actually show
this to you in a distance formula video
but the distance formula just comes out
of the pythagorean theorem and if that's
not completely obvious for you just
think about it a little bit and it'll
hopefully become a little bit more
obvious but anyway this was probably you
probably already knew this and actually
just so just to hit the point home if if
we had an equation like this
x squared
plus y squared is equal to nine
the graph of this circle
would look like this
so that's the x-axis that's the y-axis
and draw the circle itself circle looks
like close enough
and then the distance or the radius from
the center of the circle
or the radius of the circle that's going
to be
three
just a right there's a nine you might
say oh why isn't the radius nine no
that's because this is the radius
squared remember the original formula i
just showed you x squared plus y squared
is equal to r squared
so this right here
is r squared so if r squared is equal to
nine then r is equal to three it can't
be minus three or i mean it could you
know it you can't have a negative radius
or if you did you just go in the other
direction but it's the same thing so the
radius is equal to three so that's a
circle and that's pretty straightforward
but
in a lot of algebra classes they they
complicate the issue a little bit by
shifting the circle
so let's say i had so let's say let's
just shift this circle instead of having
so let me just rewrite it
so the unshifted circle was x squared
plus y
squared is equal to let me write it this
way is equal to 3 squared right that's
the same thing as 9.
let's say that the new circle the
shifted circle is
x
minus 1
squared
plus
y
plus 2
squared is equal to 3 squared now all of
a sudden this looks really complicated
and daunting and all the rest but all
you have to recognize is we just
substituted
an x minus 1
for the whoops i messed up my pointer we
just substituted an x minus 1 for the x
and we just substituted a y plus 2
for the y so it has the same basic
pattern as
of this circle and the fact that we
added or subtracted numbers from the x's
and the y's tells us that we shifted the
circle and so the next obvious question
is where did you shift it to and your
your impulse might be oh well maybe i
shifted it to
instead of the center being 0 0 right
this has a
center
at 0 0
your intuition might be to say that well
now the center is at negative 1 plus 2
and you'd be almost right except you'd
be exactly
the opposite of the correct answer the
new center
the new center
is now
x is equal to positive 1
is x is equal to positive 1 and y is
equal to -2 and that might be
unintuitive for you at first and you
might want to watch some of the videos i
think i've done them already or i've
always intended to on shifting functions
but the way to think about it is
x you know the center here is x is equal
to zero so when you know x and y is
equal to zero x squared plus y squared
is zero or exactly zero away from the
center or we're at the center so now if
we want to be if we want x to be
zero away from our new center
this term has to be equal to zero
and if
just like when x was equal to zero this
term equaled zero so now for for us for
us to be at the center of our new circle
so to speak this term has to be zero so
the new center has to be at x is equal
to one likewise
this has to be zero and so the center is
at y is equal to two another way to
think about it is
this
what if let's say when y
you know what happens here when y is
equal to 2
what whatever part of the circle we're
in when you know y is equal to
2 right there's some part of the circle
we're at in fact i could draw it
when y is equal to two let's say this
radius is three when y is equal to two
we're probably right around there on the
circle we could be there or we could be
there right now we're shifting this
circle so now instead of being at 0 0
we're going to be at 1 minus 2.
so now we're going to be at the new
center is x is equal to 1 y is equal to
-2 the new center is there and if i were
to draw the new circle it would look
something like this i'm going to try my
best
try my best to draw it still as a circle
and show you that it's been shifted
no that's not good
let me draw it like
i
thought
when i press the wrong button
that's not good let me draw it right
there
oh that's close enough i don't have to
keep doing it so we did is we shifted
this circle
we shifted this circle
down to
and to the right one
so if we take its center point
we went down two
and to the right one and so if you think
about
up here when y was equal to 2
we could have been at this point or this
point
the kind of equivalent points of the new
circle are going to be here
are going to be roughly here where
you're shifting it down and to the right
or down and to the right and in order to
kind of have that same behavior at the
circle there
this whole thing
should be equal to
this whole thing should be equal to 2.
so this that same point on the circle if
this whole thing is going to be equal to
right because it's going to be the same
kind of behavior in the equation and i
hope i'm not confusing you there
then this the new y has to be 0 and you
see it there right at both of these
points now
y is equal to 0. so i know that's a
little unintuitive but i want you to sit
and think about that a lot i mean you
could just memorize it that it's you
know that it's the opposite when you
have x minus 1 and y plus 2 that it's
actually you've shifted to x is equal to
the center is now 1 minus two or you
could memorize if you like that you know
what makes this zero and what makes this
zero and that's your new center but i
really want you to think about that this
is really a shift and of course if you
were to graph it you were to get this
thing
up there
anyway let me see how much time i have
actually i didn't even keep track of the
time i'll leave you there i'll continue
this in the next video where i'll talk a
little bit about ellipses